قال الرئيس الفرنسي من هو الماكرون ان
الوقت الان ليس للحوار او التفاوض فقد
اختارت روسيا الحرب ويجب مواجهتها اضاف
ماكرون في كلمته امام مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
انه من الضروري مواجهه روسيا والعمل على
تقويه موقف اوكرانيا التفاوضي
اريد ان اقول بوضوح واجبنا هو اظهار روسيا
كقوه مزعزعه للاستقرار العالمي ومخله
بالتوازن ليس فقط في اوكرانيا بل في
القوقاز والشرق الاوسط وافريقيا من خلال
استخدام قوات فاجنر التي اصبغت عليها
موسكو الصفه الرسميه انا شخصيا تحدثت مع
بوتين قبل عام خلال محادثات تجنب الحرب
قال لي وبكل ثقه لا يمثلوننا باجنر هي
اداه عسكريه ودبلوماسيه ومافياويه جديده
لروسيا
وفي كلمه امام المؤتمر خلال المستشار
الالمانيتو سيواصل العمل على تحقيق
التوازن بين دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا ومنع
اندلاع حرب بين الحلف وروسيا
نزود اوكرانيا باحدث الاسلحه والذخائر
اكثر من اي بلد في اوروبا وسنواصل فعل ذلك
لقد غيرت المانيا مبادئ تاريخيه من اجل
دعم اوكرانيا واقول للرئيس الروسي ليس
اسلحتنا ما سيطيل امد الحرب وانما متى ما
فهم بوتين استحاله تحقيق اهدافه فان نهايه
الحرب ستكون اسرع سنعمل على تحقيق التوازن
بين دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا وعدم اندلاع حرب
بين النيتو وروسيا يجب ان يسود الحذر من
اي استعجال واي قرار بشان امدادات الاسلحه
وسنواصل اتخاذ القرار المناسب